in a previous video we explored the
sampling distribution
that we got when we took the difference
between sample
proportions and in that video we
described the distribution in terms of
its mean standard deviation and shape
what we're going to do in this video is
build on that example and try to answer
a little bit more about it so in this
situation what we want to do is find the
probability given that we what we
already know
about this sampling distribution's mean
and standard deviation and shape we want
to find the probability that the sample
proportion of defects from plant b
is greater than the sample proportion
from
plant a so pause this video and see if
you can figure this out all right now
let's do this together so first of all
let's just interpret what this is
the probability that the sample
proportion of defects from plant b
is greater than the sample proportion
from plant
a so the sample proportion from plant b
is greater than the proportion from
plant a then the difference
between the sample proportions is going
to be negative
so this is equivalent to the probability
that
the difference of the sample proportions
so the sample proportion from a minus
the sample proportion from b
is going to be less than zero
or another way to think about it that's
going to be this area
right over here now there's a bunch of
ways that we can figure out this area
but the easiest or one of the easiest i
guess there's many different ways to do
it
is to figure out well how many this is
up to including how many standard
deviations below
the mean and then we could use a z table
so what we just have to do is figure out
what is the z value here
and the z value here we just have to say
well how many standard deviations
below the mean is this and i'll do it up
here let me
square this off so i don't make it too
messy
z is going to be equal to so we
are negative 0.02
from the mean or we're 0.02 to the left
of the mean so i'll just do negative
0.02 and then over
the standard deviation which is 0.025
which is going to be equal to get a
calculator here
we get .02
divided by .025 is equal to that
and we are of course going to be to the
left of the mean
so our z is going to be approximately
negative 0.8 or 0.8 i'm saying
approximately because this was
approximate over here when we figured
out the standard deviation
so it is negative 0.8
and then we just have to use a z lookup
table
and so if we look at a z lookup table
what we see here
is if we're going to negative 0.8
negative 0.8
is right over here so negative 0.8 and
then we have
zeros after that so we're looking at
this right over here
the area under the normal curve up to
and including
that z value so we always have to make
sure that we're looking at the right
thing on this
standard normal probabilities table
right over here
that gives us 0.21 or we could say this
is approximately
21 percent so let me get rid of this
and so we know that this right over here
is
approximately 21
or we could say 0.21 so the probability
of the sample proportion of defects from
plant b
is greater than the sample proportion
from plant a
it's give or take it's roughly one in
five